[Music]
thank you
I don't generally make build videos as
there are plenty of YouTubers out there
that cover the side of things already
but I keep getting asked what I'm
running in my last couple of videos so I
thought screw it I have some spare time
this afternoon and given the type of
build this is it should only take a few
minutes to run through I will never
claim a build as being the best of its
type because this is just something that
works for me with my style of play and
the platform I play on I'll always
recommend using these as a template for
yourself and adapt it based on your
needs there will always be another build
out there that will provide more DPS
survivability or whatever else you're
looking for
this Loadout is fully based around the
Striker's battle gear set since the
recent revamp of the set it has become
my most used build for General
activities mainly because I love doing
high damage however like most DPS builds
it comes with a drawback of lacking a
little on the survivability side of
things so as you'll soon see I've had to
pull back on a little bit of the damage
in order to counter this
I'm not going to read through the set
perks or each individual piece because
I'm sure you can read for yourself but
summing the setup shoot stuff do more
damage
I'm using four pieces of Strikers The
Mask backpack gloves and Holster
the backpack because it boosts the
damage from 0.65 to 1 per stack but I
don't bother with the chess piece I like
this piece in group play or in countdown
but when playing solo most waves of
enemy aren't large enough or have enough
hit points to really be able to take
advantage of the extra Stacks so instead
I run the chesca chest chesca chest yeah
with the obliterate Talent this provides
a damage boost that is more immediately
available during small encounters plus
it has the added brand set attribute of
plus 10 critical hit chance
on the knee pads I'm using yield
faithful Fox's prayer mainly for the
mock applicative plus eight percent
damage to targets out of cover
all pieces have been rolled into weapon
damage for the core attribute and
critical hit damage and all chance as
the secondary attribute
I'm not going to tell you where these
need to be placed as it will depend on
the pieces you have at your disposal
just try and get as close as you can to
60 critical hit chance and pump the
wrist into critical hit damage
on my build I have 56.5 critical hit
chance and 141 critical hit damage but
you should be able to squeeze a little
more out of this
the weapons are whatever you feel
comfortable with the Famas is one of my
favorites because of the ridiculous rate
of fire although this build provides a
little bit of weapon handling you may
still find The Recoil a little bit too
much to control so you could instead
look at the carbine 7 or the king
breaker with higher damage and lower RPM
the talent I've chucked onto this is
Preservation to help with survivability
the secondary weapon is the rock and
roll shotgun to build the stacks quickly
but to be completely honest with the
rate of fire of the Famas I don't use
this often you could instead use a
weapon with a little bit of range
especially if you were using an SMG as
humane
the specialization is gonna mainly
because of the 10 armor on kill and five
percent rate of fire on kill
the skills are reviver Hive and well
whatever you want there aren't any skill
tiers with this so you aren't going to
get a huge amount from whatever you run
anyway I'm using the fixodrone just to
help a little bit with countering the
incoming damage
and that's pretty much it you are still
very squishy but you pack a hell of a
punch make sure to utilize cover well
but you need to play aggressive and keep
killing in order to keep a steady stream
of armor coming in like I said earlier
there are a ton of ways to get much more
damage out of the set but as a solo
player on heroic this is more than
enough
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]